[Music]
the philosopher Ernest Becker in his
book the denial of death says that the
human situation haha is so terrifying
when you really consider the big picture
that to not go mad would amount to
another form of madness now the
philosopher Kierkegaard has an
interesting definition of the
schizophrenic and he compares and
contrasts that schizophrenic to the
depressive now basically he says the
schizophrenic is overwhelmed by too much
possibility the schizophrenic is privy
to too much vision too much ecstasy he
simply is overwhelmed he is flooded by
an overbearing amount of sense
impressions impregnated with so much
meaning with so much signification that
he is torn apart by the simple fact that
there's no possible way that he can ride
every single one of those sense
impressions he can't be here and there
everywhere the schizophrenic is torn
apart because he simply is obliterated
and it's not grounded in any way he's
pulled in every possible direction that
you can pulled unfiltered terrifying
like a living wake walking nightmare the
depressive on the other hand has the
illusion that the walls are caving in on
him he simply cannot envision a
different situation for himself the
depressive is subject to a failure of
the imagination he is stuck with too
much entropy too much gravity the here
now sucks and he cannot imagine another
possibility for himself in other words
the world is caving in there is nothing
but despair he is too grounded so again
this pizza phrenic not grounded enough
pulled apart by too much possibility the
depressive - grounded - in his body
cannot transcend his own weight it's a
failure of the imagination
to contrasts to extremes loosely defined
most of us probably finding ourselves
somewhere in-between but nonetheless an
interesting definition and a creative
challenge to each and every one of us
how do we partake in these
beautification these ecstatic visions
and nightmarish perspectives and
leverage them and try to create a life
for ourselves that is at the very least
filled with a little bit of grace
[Music]
you